when you go through situations like that
you know
the muslims should know okay
there is a wisdom behind this this is
you know that we learn theoretically
this is implementing akida
in
practicality me knowing allah is
al-hakim he's the most wise i've hit a
wall right now i've failed my college
exams i failed my uni exams my parents
really want me to do this
oh allah
you know every single scenario that
could have happened in my life
and for some reason this is the scenario
that you chose
to happen
there must be some wisdom in this yeah
there must be some wisdom in this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with the very special guest brother
musa salaam alaikum
doing a little better now that we got
you on subhanallah like a year ago just
over a year ago we didn't even have this
podcast and i remember watching videos
of you interviewing you know all the
greats in in the dallas team
and i was just like yo i want to be like
that one day and and nowhere that if
someone told me like in a year from here
you're going to be you know talking to a
lot of people that are in the dallas
scene you're going to be doing your best
to do dawah and bro i would say like no
way that's that's cap there's there's no
way that's possible
um and now we're here alhamdulillah
and uh really fortunate to have the
opportunity to speak to you bro
may allah bless you bro i guess that's
how life is man subhanallah
i've had
similar experiences in my life where
you know
you you don't you don't you don't know
what you're going to be doing in five
years you know subhanallah even a few
years ago
um the stuff that i'm doing now you know
if you told me that i'm going to be
doing it
i i would never expect it and it just
goes to show us how allah
you know is guiding us along our way you
know we may think we're in control but
in reality you know uh it's allah who's
blessing us alhamdulillah
he says himself
uh that he could he would provide for
those basically those the good doers
from places they never even imagined and
this is something i have personally
experienced and i'm sure honestly
many people in the world have
experienced and it reminds me of
something mufti mike said where he said
um when
things go his way or things go according
to his plan he said alhamdulillah once
and when things don't go according to
his plans alhamdulillah twice
once for um basically it not happening
according to what he wanted and the
second one for allah intervening and
doing exactly what he will so i think
that that's beautiful
man um so this being said when you when
you mentioned you know five years ago
you know
just like just like what i was saying
you wouldn't know that you'd be here
right now and or even like even a year
ago or two years ago so i don't know
because no one knows and we can't we
can't anticipate these things we can't
retrospectively look you know forward
into our lives and see what's to come um
but it's also important to be present in
the moment um so for you um personally
how do you manage goal setting or or
let's say you know the direction you
want to propagate towards while also
understanding okay i got to be in the
present moment focus on what allah wants
for me etc
yeah subhanallah i think that's i think
that's a brilliant question and for me
personally um
i i think it's about
trying your best because this is
something that like um
a lot of people like we all have
expectations for ourselves right
so like um i i think every single person
has a certain image of what they want to
be in their head
so
you know um
if you're a brother you know you may
have a specific image of what you would
like your body to look like you know
going to the gym and stuff like that in
a year when six months
um things that you want to know even if
it being islamic knowledge you know
let's say you want to memorize the quran
you know you have certain like things
that you want
i think i think sometimes
it's important to not get too worked up
on
what you want
i think it's important to try and get to
where you want but also allow allow for
allah subhana wa ta'ala to guide you
along that
because sometimes like you may work hard
for something
and
you don't get it
you don't get it and some people you
know um they may
they may they may feel like okay and
there's a balance as well so like
let's use the example of memorizing the
quran right
so
let's say you're working hard for
memorizing the quran and
you're finding it difficult what some
people might do in the beginning is give
up or feel like you know
it's it's something that
i i i kind of you know
maybe it's not for me right and they
might not say that but it's it's
something that a person might do
um
so i think uh what happens in that type
of situation is you should you should
persist and try hard but there's other
situations in life where you're trying
to you know get to somewhere and it's
just not happening
nothing is happening right you have a
specific goal and it's just not
happening for you um
and and it's as if allah is pointing you
in another direction
okay so you might want to go to a
specific university and study
but
every thing that's happening in your
life it's like pointing in a completely
different direction
and i feel like in situations like that
that's like where you know what uh
uh remy just uh you know
he mentioned about muftimec what he
mentioned
in situations like that it's as if you
know
that thing isn't for you you know maybe
you should go towards
the other thing and that might be better
for you right and sometimes that's what
happens to us in life that's exactly
what happens to us in life like
with me even personally um
university is something that my dad
um would really emphasize
you know he would really emphasize for
me and my dad's not one of those
traditional type of fathers that's like
you know
um
you know what i mean like those cultures
go to school become a doctor lawyer you
know yeah he's not like that so so but
he wanted me to go to uni because
he's like it's actually gonna for the
education of uni
so not for a career my dad never said to
me go uni because you're gonna get a
good job but he would always encourage
me to go uni because
because it's gonna
it's gonna give you certain skills you
know
um
and for a long time i didn't go uni and
i felt like i it's not really for me
and education i'm not really you know
whatever et cetera but then one day i
just i read a book
um it really inspired me
and i thought okay you know what i i
think uni might be for me
and subhanallah now i'm i'm in my final
year i'm about to graduate insha'allah
make dua for me i need i still need to
start my dissertation
but um
you know and and that's it you know i i
think it's about how it goes back to the
initial point you know uh how allah is
guiding us you know so you may have your
goals you may have your objectives but
allah has a different objective for you
and that's so important to remember so
um
sometimes it's important not to be too
hung up on your objectives and your
goals
uh to the perspective where like if if
if you're seeing allah is taking you in
a different direction and it's a good
direction maybe that's better for you
maybe that's actually better for you
yeah but my question in response not in
response but following that is yeah it's
it's kind of been painted in the way
where it's like you try something it
doesn't work out and then something
shows kind of the path opens up for you
what if you're in a situation where you
try something it doesn't work and you
just feel like you're at a wall
you don't feel that allah is god has
guided you in a specific direction
because i feel like that happens a lot
of the youth as well especially at that
point when they go from high school they
have to decide what they want to do the
rest of their life it's kind of like i
tried this it didn't work out where i
failed
now what how do you get through a tough
depressing time like that
um
subhan allah i think i think times like
that
firstly like it i i think it really
depends what you're talking about and i
think this is a very good conversation
to have i think it depends what you're
talking about like if it's education bro
subhanallah like a lot of people take
education and when i say education i
mean like western education academia
um they take it
in my opinion this is my opinion they
take it too seriously right it's like
you'll be all in and all you know
there's some families
they make
your degree
your life if you if you come home
i was watching a podcast and there was
this eritrean brother and he was talking
about and different cultures are
different he was saying that eritreans
for them it's not even about the job or
career it's just about uni you know it's
just about the paper you know you don't
even need to have a job afterwards it's
just going uni
and you know how dropping out of uni not
going to uni such a big thing for them
you know even in the pakistani culture
i'm originally pakistani
like for us
culturally speaking you know if you
didn't go uni
it's like
you know some people might see you as a
failure anyway
um and i remember there was a story here
um of this a young man
um who went missing i don't know if it
reached you guys um you guys are in
america right we're in canada canada
okay mashallah i love canada um
i like canada i was in canada um uh like
a couple years ago i really enjoyed it
but um
yeah i don't know if the story reached
you was a news story here it was it was
pretty big you know there's a big forest
we have it called epping forest
and this guy went missing he was found
in epping forest dead
okay and i think he had killed himself
and he was in a good university
and they linked his death directly to
university
university stress the stress he was
going through at university right
and
one thing that that made me reflect on
is how seriously people take this okay
um and how how important certain people
have made it and it goes back to the
question
it depends what we're talking about if
we're talking about you know uni you
know
and you feel like okay you're failing
your exams or it's not for you etc what
not alhamdulillah like for me personally
if that happened to me
it's not that deep
you know
it's it's like okay maybe this isn't for
me
maybe i need to find something else
maybe i need to make some dua i need to
and i really think this is where islam
comes in yeah a lot of people don't
realize
that for us knowing our purpose as
muslims knowing why we're here
um you know as allah says in suratul
you know all of these concepts they're
not just theoretical things
and it really annoys me when we as
muslims make these ayats in the quran
and these concepts from islam
theoretical
meaning
we believe in them but they don't
reflect anything in our actions you know
we still we're basically we behave just
the same as kufar we behave exactly the
same as hindus and christians and and
others atheists
um from the perspective if we fail an
exam we behave the same you know if if
something doesn't go well for us in life
we behave exactly the same and it
shouldn't be like that yeah that means
you haven't understood islam in its in
its essence you know understanding islam
in its essence you know when you go
through situations like that
you know
the muslims should know okay
there is a wisdom behind this this is
you know that we learn theoretically
this is implementing akida
in practicality
me knowing allah is al-hakim he's the
most wise i've hit a wall right now i've
failed my college exams i filmed my uni
exams my parents really want me to do
this
oh allah
you know every single scenario that
could have happened in my life
and for some reason this is the scenario
that you chose
to happen
there must be some wisdom in this yeah
there must be some wisdom in this bro i
feel like any time you have tawakkul and
allah when you don't get what you wanted
to dunya it really doesn't matter that's
it's not that deep as long as you have
your fair straight with allah like i i
don't say this to both but bro i'm
currently in uh studying medicine and
i'm like seven years deep bro i got
three more to go
and uh or two and a half to go and i'm
saying this right now whenever i say
this to people they always they're like
bro what are you saying like are you
crazy but i always say inshallah i never
have to practice because what i want to
do once i'm done is take a more academic
islamic education and and continue doing
dollar full-time and this is all i want
to do i don't know about rami i don't
know about angel but
i definitely know this is why we started
the podcast this is what gives me
fulfillment in life when i have my fair
straight with that that's what helps me
wake up and do what i do and not you
know
yeah okay you know being a doctor i know
a lot of people watching including my
parents they're probably gonna be like
come on like i know but bro look at
zakir naik uh dr sabi lahmad a lot of
people have left
dunya worldly careers for doing dawah
because there's it helps them you know
show themselves that they're doing what
they can for allah and for the sake of
allah not just for the dunya
now can you do that in adonia means of
course but that's what we're talking
about right and what links to what you
were saying too is
the whole desi culture too but not just
desi culture just a lot of parents in
general they really put that stress so
that brother um that probably took his
own life you know because of uni
yeah it's probably him but we also got
to see where that that culture is coming
from where that's propagating from too
um so i want to say like for the record
my grandfather that this man's a real g
like 100
he's the only guy i know in my entire
brown family who whenever he calls me
the first thing he says is are you
praying everyone is how school going or
did you get your degree are you this are
you are you passing your courses
all he asks are you praying and i'm
always like
yes and he's like that's all i need to
know
but that's the thing right you know uh
he's associating success clearly you
know evidently or the most important
thing
with in reality the most important thing
you know and for and this is what shows
you why some of our communities are
really messed up in their thinking and
we have to say it how it is right
you know your community is messed up
right
when
you could go to your father or your
mother and say
you know i missed all of my salawat last
week
and they won't really react that you
know oh they might be upset or whatever
if if they're upset
and you know they'll get over it
basically they'll get over you telling
them that they probably won't even
remember in a week okay
but
try the same thing with telling them oh
you know what i've left uni because i
want to pursue a different path i want
to i want to i want to launch a business
right
it's not and it shows you
how
you know things have and and this is not
and i'm sure this is none of our point
right we're not here to
um
you know just trash university
that's not what we're doing right but
the point is putting things in their
proper places
and subhanallah i actually personally
feel like
when you put uni in the proper place you
actually enjoy it more
you actually enjoy it more you know
you actually feel like okay you know i'm
here it's good it's an experience for me
i'm going to learn i'm going to study
and the pressure goes away you know
there's no there's no fear of failure
exactly exactly there's no fear of
failure so so you enjoy it more
and the pressure should be in in the
real important things
like salah like etc and subhanallah you
know my my father one of his uncles
passed away
you know i'm in pakistan
and i remember when he passed away my
dad mentioned something very interesting
and my dad um he mentioned that and it's
so true like when people pass away
like no one cares about
you know what uni you went to when you
pass away and this even those people who
in this dunya
like these cultural parents even these
people they don't care when you when
you've died they don't care what uni you
went to
or you know what job you had
what do people mention cultural people
religious people everyone what do they
mention when when when someone's passed
away oh mashallah you know him
he built a village in
someone so place he built a masjid in
his village
he was he was a person of sadaqah he was
a person he used to read the quran allah
now all of a sudden the akhira comes out
right
and and and this is a mentality that
you know if if our parents don't have it
obviously we have to approach them with
respect and mannerisms and stuff but we
definitely as young people should have
it so i'm going back to rami's you know
an initial point
i think that if you're a young person
chances are and you've hit a wall
firstly chances are what you
define what you define as a young person
who hasn't experienced life yet properly
as a big problem and a big thing it
might not even be a big issue right in
the grand scheme of things you know
in the grand scheme of things it's
probably not a big deal right um
and we have to go with um and we have to
have that reliance on allah you know and
i'm a firm believer in in in in
actualizing
that way you know when we think of
allah's
you know al-khabib you know
all of these things they mean so much
you know they mean so much so when you
understand that you know allah is with
me
you know
yeah like all of these ayat in the quran
when you actualize them
you you will have
the comfort that you need to to live
your life you know
i think it's important
but i know both of you can agree with
this point that a big
factor that's driving force between
behind this is is people are too heavily
relying on the system because the system
perpetuates itself in a way where
it yields this victim mentality unless
we have the system to protect us and
give us everything that's why when
someone says that i want to pursue this
and i want to leave uni the parents are
like what do you mean because uni you
know mentally subconsciously gives them
this this uh security factor right where
it's like you know i want to have kids
and it's like how are you gonna have
kids you don't have kids but they don't
have tawako because allah puts barakah
in their marriage and in their family
once they have kids but they have the
order mixed up because they're thinking
okay system you gotta pay taxes you
gotta have money you don't have money so
are you gonna have kids right
yes
just on the side no just to piggyback
off that point the amount of people i
went to and i i pulled the ayah in the
quran
he says if two poor slaves get married
for the sake of allah allah will enrich
them i quote that to them as like like
premise number one premise number two
let me marry your daughter right like
that's premise number one
and
and they're like
heck no as if i quoted them a quote from
harry potter or something
and that's that's a shame in my opinion
but that's the thing like subhanallah
when you when you look at
um you know the dunya
in the context of the quran you know
allah subhanahu ta'ala mentions the
dunya
over a hundred times and he doesn't
praise it
you know we as muslims um we we need to
really realize these things you know
and and
i i think our elders as well need to
really realize these things that from a
quranic perspective you know the dhoni
is not something that's praised you know
beltwhy
you know what what do they mean why is
allah telling us this for it's you know
uh the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he had the choice he could have
lived in a luxurious manner like the
kings of this world you know uh
you know a hundred thousand companions
he was a king he had he he had enough
people you know beneath him you know to
live like a king but subhanallah the
prophet salallahu what we know from his
life he lived the simple life he lived a
simple humble life as the prophet
muhammed somewhat or someone would enter
upon the prophet saws and his companions
they would not be able to distinguish
between the prophet sallallahu sallam
and his companions allahu akbar and even
in this day and age it's not like that
if you were to if you were to oftentimes
go into a masjid
and there's a giving a lecture you would
probably be able to distinguish between
the sheikh and the others right and
that's not me saying anything bad about
you but it's saying look at how the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam was
right
dunya was something that you know
the like the statement of ali
he made a statement he said
he said be children of
meaning like be a people of the akhirah
right these companions
you know
they had the akira
instilled inside them you know it
reminds me
um
there was um after the battle of uhud
right it was after the battle of uh
there was a lady from banu dinar okay
she had lost her husband
in the battle she had lost her husband
her father and her brother
at the battle of ahud yeah
when she found this out or when the army
you know when she saw the army and she
engaged with the army what does she ask
she asks
and of course i paraphrase
she's asking how is the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi
how is the prophet salallahu and they're
like you know he's okay but she wanted
to see the prophet salallahu that he's
okay you know and when she sees that the
prophet salallahu is okay what does she
express
all of these misfortunes all of these
you know things that have happened to me
are nothing if you're okay
you know subhanallah and this is how the
companions were
they they they lived their life as
people who who they were willing to
sacrifice things for
and that's not us saying live broke live
like and and this is an unfortunate
thing people don't realize when you have
this mentality allah provides for you
and me personally i don't know about you
guys you guys can comment on this right
but from what i've seen the people who
have seen who are comfortable in terms
of dunya masha'allah
and as in they live the type of life you
would want to live they're people who
are not people who are chasing dunya
they're not people like that
and subhanallah like it's clear you know
allah subhanahu ta'ala has make things
made things clear for us
you mentioned them in their mentality
because the prophet saw he did and we
can see in the hadith that he did such
an amazing job of instilling this
mentality in them and just this hadith
i'm about to like paraphrase just
imagine where amongst the sahabah so the
sahaba the process and they're walking
through the market
and
the process on he sees a dead goat like
a dead goat carcass on the floor
and he picks it up by the ear and he
kind of holds it from in front of him to
the sahaba and he's like who wants to
buy this from me
and the sahaba at the
like why would we want to buy that like
it's rotting it's gross there's no use
why would we
we wouldn't even take it if he gave it
to us for free that's what they said in
the process he said that the dunya in
the eyes of allah is lower it's less
than this this dead goat in your eyes
it's found a lot how can we hear a
hadith like that
and then run and dedicate our lives to
getting
even even just like even a million
dollars something less like sounds like
crazy to a lot of people even a million
dollars in this world one you know the
process suddenly said that
before
is is worth the the dunya and everything
in it or is greater than the dunya and
everything in it that is that i think
this is what we need to start
propagating to the youth this is what we
need to start teaching them
and i'm glad you mentioned the elders
before as well because it's allah it's a
shame that allah bless them and have
mercy on them that a lot of them
including like my own upbringing it
didn't have that that backing in akedah
they didn't teach you the hadith of the
prophet sallam where he literally
teaches you the formula to get stronger
to not fall into depression and i want
to mention this before when you were
talking about when you hit a wall and
answering that question
and the prophet said
he said that
the strong believer is better and more
beloved allah than the weak believer and
there's good in everyone usually you
hear that and then like
hadith it continues because that that
begs the question how do you get strong
what do you mean by strong how do you
get strong prostate cancer he says
cherish that hold on to that which gives
you benefit
and and uh
trust in allah have to
and don't become faint-hearted don't
become weak-hearted don't lose hope and
then that makes a question okay how do i
not lose hope or how what would cause me
to lose hope he says if anything comes
to you in the form of something
difficult or hard
don't say
if only i took that major instead if
only i i didn't go ask for that girl's
hand image if only i took this job and
said rather say called it allah and
allah does he wills
that that has honestly kept me going i
would say for the past few years
yeah you know this stuff is so important
um and i i honestly think if we just
spoke about this
you know for for a whole podcast
it would be an amazing thing to speak
about like meaning this if you can go
home with this by itself this is an
amazing amazing thing to realize that
the things that are happening to you
even the mistakes that you're making you
know
they're setting you up for something in
the future this is the allah knows what
he's doing with you you know subhanallah
and
how many times do you hear stories where
like people
you know they were at the lowest point
of their lives
and because of that lowest point
they ended up seeing the highest point
of their lives the best thing ever
happened to them you know some people
you know they've gone through divorce
you know and they're like it's the best
thing that happened to me you know i i
i'm grateful to allah that happened to
me and subhanallah actually you find
people who don't accept the qatar of
allah
those people how they live their lives
as well
some people they just can't
it's it's it's like they're stopping
themselves from reaching what we're
talking about you know this tranquility
this um
the
this peacefulness inside you you know
when i when you accept the qatar of
allah you reach a level of peacefulness
inside you you know alhamdulillah
i have to work within allah allah is
doing something good for me insha allah
right there is hikma in this there's
knowledge in this allah can see what i'm
doing right but then there's some people
who are like no
you know i'm not happy with what's
happening to me this is terrible this is
you know and and and it's as if like
they're not happy with the qatar of
allah they're not happy with what allah
is decreeing for them
and and as a result of their unhappiness
it's like they're just messing things up
for themselves further yeah
yeah that's that's actually i would say
exactly how depression happens either
you lose something that you feel you
should have and that causes you
depression or you you feel like you lack
something that you should have something
you never had that you feel you deserve
and it's only then that you feel that
cognitive dissonance that my life should
be like this or it used to be like this
and it's not like that that that throws
you into depression that throws you to
having panic attacks anxiety attacks and
having a dreadful life and this is
exactly basically what allah says that
you don't remember me if you would
remember me and my blessings upon you my
favors upon you and that to be
completely honest you don't deserve you
know entitled to everything and that
what allah gives you is actually perfect
for you with that kind of mentality
there's no room for you to even think or
feel that you're you're missing out on
something because you would technically
have everything there's actually a
beautiful narration i think of two
companions who were sitting by the ocean
and they're they had just like dry bread
and they were dipping it into the water
uh to make it basically edible to make
it something they can put in their mouth
and and swallow without it you know
hurting and i believe one company said
to the other that the the the kings of
persia and rome and like all these
different places if they knew what we
had the amen that we had they would send
armies to come take it from us
and these were people that were living
like what would see as luxurious lives
subhanallah so
let's say that you have a muslim who's
brought up in a culture or family who is
uh kind of taught that you should go to
universities to have a mediocre job and
so on and so forth they listen to this
podcast and they're starting to have
this dichotomy that you know maybe
that's not how life should be maybe i
should you know change my arcada and in
terms of what allah and the prophet
taught where should they start what's
the first thing they should establish in
their mind
um i think
firstly
the typical thing with a lot of people
and this is very typical and it's very
very cliche
my parents want me to go to university i
don't want to go to university i want to
do this i want to do that i want to you
know do something else right
and i even think even this type of
mentality can be dangerous
right or not maybe not dangerous but
why don't you want to go university for
you know why don't you want to go
university you know for me personally
one of one of my intentions
um and this is something personal but i
don't mind sharing it for the benefit
one of my intentions to go university
was
for it to be a form of berwali
for it to be a form of me doing good
towards my parents
i know it will make my dad so happy for
me to go to university for me to have a
education in that way you know seen as
an education it will make my dad very
very happy um for me to get good grades
it would make him very very happy and i
want to
you know
why why would i not want to do that
right so i really think that it all
depends on your mentality some people
they act as if the only way to spiritual
success
is through you know
praying salah for example and of course
we're never going to
now that
we're never going to belittle playing
praying salah it's the best act of
worship you can do there's no doubt
about that
but
you know making your parents happy is an
amazing act of worship is an amazing act
of worship one of the pious predecessors
you know
his sibling um you know spent the night
praying
and he himself
spent the night serving one of his
parents
and he expressed i would rather do what
i done i like i would rather do what i
done
i would much rather serve my appearance
than do that pia muller that my brother
done right
and and and it shows us that for firm
the understanding that they had so some
of us young people the the mentality
that we have is i don't want to go uni
which is something that our parents want
us to do i want to do x y and z instead
right
for me personally i mean it depends on
what you want to do but for me
personally um i believe even if your
parents want you to go university and
there's no haram in you doing that it's
good in you doing that it's going to
benefit you in anything and you know
what for for
over here i know in in the uk university
is three years right um if you're doing
a normal bachelor's right in any subject
that you're doing of course medicine and
these type of courses are longer but
let's say you're doing three years right
so however why not use that three years
as an opportunity you know what in this
three years i'm going to figure out what
i want to do after uni
you know while i'm making my parents
happy i'm going to figure out what i'm
going to do after uni and subhanallah
you know the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he expressed to us in a
hadith
that
the middle door
you know the word that that the process
i'm using the hadith is also osap
yeah the middle door
to jannah
is basically through the pleasure of
your father
okay the father is the middle daughter
jannah
like it shows us the value of us
pleasing our parents in islam
so i i think sometimes these things we
need to look at them from a different
mentality i don't know if that answers
your question i don't know if that would
that's where you were going but
that's not me i just felt like i want to
mention that yeah yeah yeah
i mean the answer you gave is is
basically the answer you gave at the end
of the day because there's some there
are so many ways you could have answered
it right you could have said oh you know
start by establishing like you know a
better understanding of tahit if they
don't have that but the route you took
is is something that a lot of people
lack a lot of people don't have and i
think that initially what you said
basically questioning the the person's
attention i think is very important
because it does it shouldn't be a matter
of my parents want me to go to uni i
don't want to go to uni why is it why is
the subject or topic you're oriented
around university to begin with
you i feel like you've already kind of
missed the point when it becomes the
topic of should i should not go to
university because the whole point
should be allah first and foremost and
then from there you know
what allah decides is is best what's
moral obeying your parents and so on and
so forth and then you can kind of i
guess away everything in accordance to
your situation so i'm glad that you you
didn't take that traditional kind of you
know just pray and fast and uh i think i
think the parents achieve like
i don't think it's emphasized enough
i just don't think it is and maybe you
know a lot of the times when when it is
spoken about it's spoken about by like
older mashai
or like people who are seen as elders
but you know us guys mashallah we're
young you know and i hope that some of
the audience will see that you know
we're just like them in that way we're
young as well and sometimes when when
people say things like what i'm saying
the person hearing you on the other side
assumes that you know i've never gone
through a struggle with my parents do
you know what i mean like when we hear
stuff like this from older people it's
as if oh his relationship you know my
parents are abusive and and people have
what are this type of stuff to say right
um the fact of the matter is i'm sure
every single one of us has our own
struggles with our parents i'm sure that
sometimes our parents say things to us
that we don't like to hear they know
exactly what button to press exactly
what to say
but
having subber with them the reward of
that you know
being good to your parents you know you
know subhanallah the prophet he
expresses us in hadith that you know the
the pleasure of allah is in the pleasure
of of your father of your parents
you know subhan allah like these things
are practical ways of us getting closer
to allah and these are acts of worship
no make no mistake these are acts of
worship
islam even
in his book
he describes what an act of worship is
and it's anything that allah subhanahu
ta'ala loves
anything allah loves is an act of
worship allah loves for you to be good
to your parents right so it's an act of
worship um so if we're talking about you
know doing good things and what not of
course no doubt about it learning about
allah learning to heed um praying your
salah being more conscious of allah
being someone who you know knows more
about allah is important but these
practical things that we can do in our
lives are also very important yeah and
100 you know all i find it funny before
i let fire jump in here um when you
mention that
you don't hear this about the parents
except from the parents themselves when
a young person hears it from the parent
or from their parents especially their
grandparents it becomes like you're just
using that because like it benefits you
that's what it sounds like yeah and yeah
i remember distinctly when i was younger
i wasn't very practicing you know when i
was a kid but
i would pray behind you know certain
elders and
i swear every single time they would
lead us in prayer they would recite that
verse specifically
and you know may allah forgive me i was
a young boy i remember sitting there
like you're just reciting that because
like
you don't want us to like you know
disagree with you or something like that
but all of that kind of mentality is so
toxic
that kind of mentality itself is so
toxic so alhamdulillah i'm glad that you
mentioned that because i can imagine you
know there being a million of me young
me's out there kind of thinking the same
thing because it's not based in in
people like you know adding scripture or
saying scripture because it benefits
them
it's it's based on what allah himself
like you said what he loves and i think
that was a beautiful way to phrase it
but fired bro where is your your mind at
right now on this
bro listen hearing hearing you guys
talking about about this it really begs
the question that brother musa adnan
being here right now
ustad adnan rasheed when we had him on
he was speaking a little bit about you
know
raising kids and and how he you know
influenced you guys and he didn't really
impose university or education in a
strict way or tell you guys what to do
but instead set the precedents and
guidelines and examples for you guys to
follow and i think that's a very
superior way of parenting compared to
just you know forcing kids to do x y and
z so this being said what are three
important lessons that you learned from
your father
allah that's an amazing question
um and yeah that's that's true by the
way what you mentioned for me my dad you
know he encouraged me to do things and
whatnot but subhan allah like it's like
i ended up going uni i ended up doing
exactly what he studied you know you
know and without him imposing it i could
have done politics or whatever else i
wanted to do but other allah i done
history alhamdulillah um three things
i would say three things that i get from
my father
number one i'll say strength
and when i say that i mean it generally
the way i look at my father this is the
perception i have in my head of my
father
is a very strong person
and i don't necessarily mean physically
only but i mean
strong-minded very strong-minded um i
don't know if that's because my dad was
raised you know back home and i know
people back home are just different
breed masha'allah a lot of the time but
he's very strong-minded masha'allah
and he's if he holds an opinion he's
very strong on that opinion um he's he's
that that's the way i described and i
respect that and i think it's it's a
good way to be um that's one thing
um
another thing masha'allah um that has
inspired me recently and i think it's
it's a good it's a good thing to mention
is um
you know when he does something
you know
um you know when i like for example his
field is history and he's very
interested in history
and subhanallah it reminds me of the
hadith you know
you know
the prophet he basically expressed
susana hadith that
allah has written for you to have a son
you know excellence in every single
thing that you do and subhanallah um
when when i even on a personal level i'm
sitting with my father
you know and he's discussing you know
history
i'm blown away i'm simply blown away you
know um
and like i'll give you guys an example
and it's actually i just click my notes
and it's open
so my my father i often hear him quoting
like um
chronological things dates and he's a
historian he's expecting well i said to
him you know what let's sit down right
now and this was a few nights ago it was
at night just me and him i said let's go
let's do an islamic chronology
yeah
um from your head basically and the vast
majority up until the end it was done
from his head right and subhanallah this
is basically i can show you this this
this is a whole chronology that was done
from his head and these are dates so he
starts the prophet saws passing the
reign of abu bakr um
going through each
caliph he ruled from here to here he
will remain
all over the top of his head so that's
another thing i really really respect
you know that
the zeal of knowledge um in him
and i would say the third thing
uh is
um
i guess being easy going as well he is
someone that's easy going you know
easy going
he's an easygoing person and i think
being easy going in your own life like
not getting worried too much not taking
too much worry
and not taking too much burden
is a good thing um so you're not
necessarily talking about being laid
back attitude but more like outcome
independence
yeah so i'm not talking about being lazy
necessarily like not lazy or stuff like
that but i mean like
like let's say we're going through a
really tough situation some people are
the type of people they just worry
they panic
their worry will kill them you know
i'm speaking metaphorically of course
yeah um but my dad my father he's like
the type of person
um
i'm not saying he doesn't get worried
but like he's he's more like
he is what he is kind of thing you know
and he deals with he's he's very easy
going in that way uh even just generally
like um with uni i'll give you an
example of uni you know i've gone to my
father in the past and this is a very
human thing to do like i worry as well
about my my own self and stuff like that
so i've gone to him in the past and i've
basically said to him you know i really
want to get good grade in this already
you know i'm i'm kind of overthinking
about this assignment or i don't know
what and he's just like now take it easy
you know it's like no take it easy like
whatever even if you get uh
you know this great or whatever it's
fine it is what it is kind of thing and
that's what i mean when i say like laid
back like
at the same time you tell me know you
have to work your hardest but yeah
these are the things that came to my
head by the way
they're not necessarily the most
important things
and i think our fathers
are like that for all of us man i think
they should be at least
um
and if if anyone's watching because
sometimes some people
um when because my dad's public and i'm
public as well sometimes people they
look at us and they just think that
you know um
like for me i'll be honest with you guys
like in only in the last two years
i've actually appreciated
my father for his own work
you know properly i feel you know that
doesn't mean i didn't appreciate it
before but it's like oh you know
mashallah your dad and he does this and
he does that you know people come up to
you and they say things
or it must be really amazing too you
know and people say stuff like this
um but it's only recently and i'm
grateful to allah for giving me this but
it's only recently where i felt like
i've had
um
i've had the capability to appreciate
what my dad's done for me
um
and what he's done in his life and i
think that that was an effort from
myself
that was an effort for myself and i
think that's something where a lot of us
need to make because sometimes us as
children it goes back to the wider
question of parents sometimes us as
children it's as if we expect our
parents to come down to our level
and
make everything make our relationships
good and make everything you know i
don't know if you guys are with what i'm
trying to say
but with them
i feel like it's important for us
to initiate that with our parents you
know
um go up to your parents say say that
you love them you know oh yeah you want
to take them out you know initiate that
you know make that because at the end of
the day
your parents are your jannah you know
it's not necessarily the same the
opposite way you know it's not as
emphasized the opposite way so you need
to work for it you know and and that's
the mentality i have i want to work for
it more you know and i need to work for
it more
yes may allah grant us
so i want to just quickly mention
something you remind me of in the quran
and i want to ask you a question about
that point so i don't remember the ayah
specifically
or exactly what it says but i remember
the context was basically the father of
ibrahim at islam
he said to his son when his son was
calling him to worship allah alone and
not forge idols not worship them he
basically pulled out the i took care of
you your whole life card and ibrahimo
islam he didn't say like you know yeah
but you're a kafir doesn't count or
anything like that he showed
appreciation towards his father for that
although at the same time his father was
making idols and worshipping idols and
not believing in allah which is the most
important thing so even someone like his
father who turned against him
with the entire community to have him
killed he still showed that appreciation
i think that's penalized it was a real
eye-opener for me specifically but
when you say that you appreciate you
just come to be able to appreciate your
father's work
more wholesomely now
what i would i would ask what aspects of
it
or can you elaborate more on what you
mean with that
um i think even even
um you know for example um and i think
it's part of maturity people see things
differently you know uh okay i i i'll
give you an example like i'm i'm i've
been involved in that alhamdulillah my
father has been as well
and in that one you have different
spheres of dawah
different perspectives different ways of
giving dawah
so my father
may or other people they may do certain
things and i myself personally i
wouldn't do those things right i don't
feel comfortable with doing those things
right
um not because i think i'm better or
anything like that it's not my style
that's that's simply it right
um
but like
in recent times and and some people will
look at certain other people's styles of
dawah
and maybe even look down on it
but in recent years i've come to
appreciate
that there's different ways of doing
things there's different ways of doing
things there's different values for
things for example you may be very
passionate about quran or hadith or
specific field and because of your
passion sometimes
you may start belittling other fields
you know you may start looking down on
other fields right
um so
and i think i think if you've been
raised with a specific father like doing
a certain thing it's very easy for you
to look in a foreign place
you know what i mean it's like
it's like if you've been raised with
biryani in your house all all of your
life
you're not necessarily going to value it
you know you're going to look at mandy
you know you're going to look at and
that's that's how i am that's literally
how i am actually right i've been raised
like some people
for them you know the food that we eat
is very very like you know nice and
they'll go to a restaurant to eat it
and with with with pakistan he's not
going to do that right he's going to he
wants to try something different
he he respects and values other things
because he's always had that his own
life
but just because you've always had
something doesn't mean you become
ungrateful for it
and i don't i don't know if this is
making it more clear so like with my
father he's always been my father i like
so sometimes even the advice your dad
will give you
your dad can tell you something and
because it's your dad and maybe even
growing up you've seen your dad's
mistakes and stuff like that so you may
belittle that advice
but you could go to a sheikh
who may be worse than your dad by the
way in his private life he may be worse
than your dad but because you don't know
his issues and whatnot and he may tell
you the exact same thing but because he
told you it you're going to listen to it
right so it's it's
with my father um alhamdulillah
what i've tried to do and what i'm uh
what what i've realized over the years
and maybe perhaps it's maturity perhaps
it's just age and growing up is that
i appreciate his advice much more now
if he was to give me advice i would take
it much more seriously now
um
i i would listen to him much more i
value his advice i value his experience
and that doesn't mean that my father's
an angel and he's never made a mistake
in his life because he's not right
but we have to be more mature about
these things uh as children to our
parents we have to forgive our parents
right we have to be kind to our parents
and i think this is something a lot of
young people can't do because their
parents they may have seen certain
mistakes from them growing up
they don't value their dad's advice
their mother's advice they don't value
and subhanallah this is your mom this is
your dad maybe if you listen to your mom
and dad's advice allah would just put
barakah because it's from your mom and
dad
because you're listening to the advice
so it's stuff like this you know
stuff like this that i think
um is very very important and i feel
like it's a secret key you know to
successes i feel like if you make your
parents happy
um
you know you're making allah happy
essentially you know and and and you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna feel
that in your life you know and the
opposite well actually you know the
opposite is true where if you're making
your parents upset
and subhanallah
our parents
they have brains
when you when your mom is giving you an
advice or your father is giving you you
an advice
and you're not taking it as seriously
as someone foreign's advice especially
if your father is someone or your mother
is someone of some islamic knowledge
right
and you're showing your parents that you
value other people's opinions more than
this
perhaps you're even
you know showing them disrespect
perhaps you're actually upsetting your
parents and as a result of upsetting
your parents perhaps you're actually
incurring sin
you know so these things are bigger than
the way we think you know um
and you know what the reward is big
and perhaps that's because the struggle
is big man
you know with a lot of us the struggle
is big you know sometimes even with me
i'll tell you this right now my dad's in
the other room right now right and i'll
tell you this right now sometimes my dad
allahu akbar he does some things right
which i'm not necessarily the biggest
fan of i struggle with them right
sometimes our characters are different
but i as a son
need to keep my mouth shut with all due
respect to myself you know i need to be
quiet i need to know my dad's place and
i need to have suburb and in that suburb
that's it
you know um
bro how many people uh brother musa do
you see that they don't value that that
person in their life or their family or
their people until they're gone and i
see this more times than when when
they're actually here with us in life
like the fact that you've you've come in
and of itself
is a blessing to the realization that
you know why your dad's still here and
and may allah give you guys a little
life and a healthy life and
the best in this life and then hereafter
but you know a lot of people they don't
have that opportunity and once they lose
that parent or that that sibling or that
spouse or that child even
and uh you know may allah protect them
and once they do they're just like oh
you know then these thoughts come up
then it's like oh i wish i did this i
wish i did that just like rami was
saying from the hadith you know i should
have done this i should have called them
more or spent more time with them or
given them more attention or or just
tried to make them happy not just be you
know so so mean or rude or whatever
you know subhanallah what you just said
deborah is is powerful and that's that's
a deep point
and that's a very important point
because some of us
um we don't realize that one day our
parents are going to go you know
subhanallah my mother she lost her
mother
um
my grandmother
um we lost her
a couple years ago now a few years ago
two two years ago
and i was very close with my grandmother
as well i grew up with her and she was
like a second mother to me and
subhanallah sometimes to this day my
mother she cries
and
and she says things about her mother and
whatnot but i'll tell you one thing
i think one thing that gives my mom
comfort is that
she knows that she was good to her
mother
you know there's another one of my
friends his father was a very famous
sheikh
okay and i won't mention who for their
own privacy
but especially in the arab world very
famous
and this son was the youngest son now in
the arab culture
the youngest son he does the most
so when you have the guest coming over
he's the one serving the tea he's the
one running around getting the food and
whatnot we have that in our culture as
well right
so he he basically mentioned to me that
he was doing this for his father and i
actually directly mentioned it to him
you know you must feel very happy and
grateful to allah like
that you done that for your father
before he passed away and now he's young
he's only like 21 22 but his father
pastor his father was old and age
um
and i'm sure he feels like that you know
and and that's how you want to leave
your parents you want to think back on
your parents alhamdulillah
at least i was good to them i was good
to them i treated them good
and and and and some people they
genuinely don't realize the value of
parents in islam you know the value
principle they have a big value a big
big value
you know after allah and the prophet
salallahu sallam you know it's your
parents there's no one else
and they're the only people alive that's
it it's your parents that's that's who
it is you know
um
so uh may allah allow us to be good to
them you know while they're with us
i mean a lot of people might be
emotional right now so uh we got to keep
it a little bit lighthearted now um you
spoke about monday right so do you guys
have any good monday near you or what
you know what uh one of my friends uh
shout out to uh muhammad zayn he's a
good friend of mine
um he's syrian he's a syrian brother
um
and he actually makes he's got mandy
oven
that he ordered from saudi so this oven
basically bro it's next level bro yeah
like
it's it's crazy so basically you put the
meat on top
and you put the rice at the bottom
and it cooks for like two hours or
whatever three hours
and
the meat from the fat from the meat
drips onto the rice
so the rice turns like yellow from the
fat
right
amazing um i've had it in restaurants
here and it's not the same though like
when when they make it when my friend
makes it when it's like homemade next
level bro that's it we're coming to the
uk
we're coming to the uk bro how far are
you from the islamic caliphate of
birmingham
islamic california
uh
i am not too far i'm not far from
birmingham because i heard there's like
there's a ton of halal food there too
and you know it's not it's not a
struggle an issue here because
alhamdulillah you know where things are
popping up here you know different halal
joints but even 10 years ago it was it
was very difficult some areas near
toronto area it's it's good but where i
am now in waterloo it's a little
difficult but alhamdulillah like there's
there's you have like vietnamese
restaurants now sushi places
everything's you know everyone's
adopting hula food
the best monday is still an hour away
bro
oh wow bro
it's good obviously we don't have the
rest even in the restaurants is decent
are you you guys are from toronto we
well i grew up in toronto and rami grew
up close to toronto and then i moved to
the city that rami moved to but now we
both live very far away well i had some
nice somali food man i had a you know
there's a place called hawash
no i've also never had tamale food bro
oh my god man you got no you guys have
got good samadhi food in in canada i
know that man amazing it's elite somali
food is elite um
there was also bro when i was in canada
i loved the french vanilla man i know
you guys are probably over it
like it was really nice um everything's
bigger over there as well like you know
you guys cubs you guys medium is like
our
you know
how large
like like masha'allah you guys uh
it's very nice man
come on do you have any plans for coming
to canada anytime soon i'd like to i'd
definitely like to i know some um i've
got some good brothers out there um as
well that i was with when i came last
time but yeah definitely i i would love
to come again inshallah
toronto was nice man inshallah
i heard there's a lot of gang violence
unfortunately it's it's it's going up
it's getting up there unfortunately may
allah protect us but uh yeah inshallah
if you come down here i'd love to take
you around show your own you know
definitely
definitely man all right i got one last
question before we wrap up this podcast
because we don't want to keep it too
long
um
very important question
and this is a very humbling question
so you know don't hold back on whatever
answer you want to give us
but what advice would you have for our
podcast we're about you know 12 months
in we want to aspire to be you know
great at what we do and you know so you
can give us things that may be uh the
three muslim specific it could be stuff
that helped you along the way so things
that you would have done differently um
so leave it to you
hello
um
now mashallah uh you guys i think you
guys are doing an amazing job um
for me personally um the podcast i was
hosting
was
it was ira's podcast it was iris podcast
i was a dao organization so
uh if i was to do a podcast
um learning from that um and in this
this all depends on how you guys want to
do things but we would i would actually
plan the podcast right so questions i
want to ask and stuff like that and
research i would actually do research
before podcasts on the topic i want to
discuss so that i had some knowledge on
it and stuff like that
um
i
i think that
one
okay i'll give you a generic advice i'll
give you a generic advice which you guys
might already be doing but i think it's
very very important if you're in public
speaking and this is a form of public
speaking what you guys are doing
um i think reading is very important
i think reading is very very important
so i would advise you guys to read
read books
especially in english
because
talking in this context
because reading
um
allows you to become more eloquent in
your speech
you build your vocabulary and it
actually allows you to present things
better
um
to to to other people and of course it
increases your knowledge as well so
that's one thing that i would say uh but
as a podcast man honestly mashallah you
guys have your own style and i've come i
came across your stuff before i came
across some of the controversial stuff
and what
some of the debates and and i don't know
what was going on before and you know
with some of the brothers mashallah but
um i came across some of that stuff that
came up on my home page um but i think
you guys are doing a good stuff good
doing good stuff and you know what you
guys should just keep it the way it is
keep it organic
um that's another thing you know
comparison is the thief of joy
so you know don't compare yourself with
other podcasts just do your own thing
and um now you guys are smashing it man
masha allah may
another very important question
do you have a historical artifact
collection like your father
oh boy do you have a chair
um
i've got there was one there's one thing
that i did take from my dad
all of my dad all of my father's stuff
is mine i'm just saying that on public
record right now anyway yeah right
and uh
it doesn't matter what my dad says yeah
i'm really joking but um
there was a man my dad he collects
manuscripts as i'm sure you guys are
aware so there was one that was really
nice the binding was nice it was it's
like a purple binding
and it's around two to three hundred
years old it's uh it's the quran from
surya sin
downwards okay so i think it's got like
seven jews around seven eight jews in it
um that's one thing that i did take i
said to my dad i'm i'm taking this this
is it's too good yeah it's really nice i
really liked it um but no i don't have
my own personal collection it's funny
you ask that because i have been
thinking about making one i i do need to
get into that inshallah but i do have my
own books
i do have my own books and they're my
books
um
it's actually happened to me before this
is a fun fact i've gone it was actually
this book this is a book that i i got
um it's it's a book on crusades
by thomas asbridge it's uh it's it's
this guy um there's a movie called the
kingdom of heaven
um he was actually the historical
advisor
but um he officially took his name out
and i don't blame him because that
movie's got a lot of inaccuracies in it
um but um
i bought this book and my dad had
already had it um so stuff like that
does happen um because my dad's got
loads and loads of books he's got
sometimes i've spoken to him about books
and he's like already i've got that book
you can take it and stuff like that so
masha'allah that's a benefit but yeah
i've got my own book so i think that's
good enough for now may allah bless you
for that man whatever whatever you want
to collect um your father's already
invited us you know when we come to the
uk to come check out his coin collection
he was flexing the second dinar you know
the official you know on the podcast and
i was kind of impressed with that you
know there's i love seeing people
passionate in something obviously you're
permissible and obviously um but just
having a passion and just
me seeing you and your father
you guys are just men of passion that
you guys have things that you love and
you guys understand yourself at that
depth and i think that's a lot of you
know identity crisis and issues and
people like that today
yeah man like like
i i think being passionate about is is
is very very important like for me
personally history
now subhanallah and maybe as we
mentioned in the beginning of the
podcast perhaps it's a nice way to end
it as well but like six seven years ago
five years ago maybe even like
um
i i don't think i would have been i
would have thought i'm going to be doing
a history degree and stuff like that or
interested in history the way i am now
but subhanallah like now
there's actually thing there's so many
benefits to reading history you know um
that i found
um
like i remember i was reading the book
um 12 years asleep
and i know they made a movie out of it
but like i was reading the actual book
the actual account written by solomon
northup and subhanallah like some of the
things that you read about what they
went through and stuff like that they'll
make you cry they'll literally make you
cry you know it made me cry
um
and um and this is history so there's so
many different dimensions to history
there's happy moments there's you know
very difficult moments emotional moments
um
and passion man yeah passion is very
very it's important to be when you are
passionate about something i think
you'll you'll thrive in that thing it's
all about just finding your passion
finding your passion
insha'allah
insha'allah inshallah 100 i think that's
that's what really kept us going for the
podcast as well that passion behind it
yeah
yeah i love that podcasting is so fun
man it's it's a it's such an enjoyable
thing yeah one hundred percent
and with that being said i guess we
passionately invite you to come on very
very soon insha'allah uh if that's it
from from fire
i was gonna say bro like
there's a lot of sisters on twitter bro
throwing shade at us you know saying
that your men should just go get therapy
instead of starting a podcast but you
know what until then this is this is
what we got to do
yeah
[Laughter]
and with that being said
allah
jesus is the only way
damn what sect were you a part of nihari
or pool
i think my family is pool
bro those are food dishes
i am happy i left islam i hated doing
wudu
fasting praying etc i accepted christ in
my heart
you were a muslim
how many rackets in wudhu
it depends on my days and mood some
muslims do five racket in wudu and the
chase will only do two
and any retraction you do now switch off
your social media i don't want to see
your face i don't want to hear your
voice
[Music]
you're a crook and a fruit star i think
there's another thing too it's it's the
perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing stocks shares
bonds you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]